avec voilà une fred frad bonjour hélène
bonjour pauline à la une de la presse la
victoire dans la nuit de rafael nadal
face à novak djokovic en quarts de
finale de roland garros mais ici c'est
rafa en français dans le texte s'il vous
plaît marca le quotidien sportif
espagnol exulte rafael nadal a donné une
leçon à novak djokovic l'a renvoyé chez
lui éprouvé qui est le roi incontesté de
la terre nadal bat djokovic lors d'une
aube volcaniques elle pèse comparé la
rivalité entre les deux joueurs à celle
qui opposa jadis les champions d'échecs
carpe
karpov et kasparov vous n'étiez pas et
pauline prochain rendez-vous pour rafael
nadal la demi finale vendredi face à
l'allemand alexander thier des sportives
elle sera hélène l'audition cet après
midi ici en france au sénat des
ministres de l'intérieur et des sports
pour s'expliquer sur les incidents du
week-end dernier au stade de france l'an
par le foot mais le fiesque de la finale
de la ligue des champions fait de
nouveau la une ce matin du quotidien
libération toujours très remonté contre
gérald darmanin qu'il accuse carrément
de mentir d'où le nez de pinocchio
darmana refait le match libé ne crois
pas aux chiffres martelé par le ministre
de l'intérieur de 30000 à 40000
personnes sans billet ou munis de faux
billets aux abords du stade de france
samedi soir un chiffre a affirmé
notamment par la ratp et des
observateurs selon le selon le quotidien
ainsi dans le stade de france affaire
damien abad alors que les difficultés
s'accumulent pour le nouveau
gouvernement les échos font état d'une
autre mauvaise nouvelle
l'accélération de l'inflation en france
+ 5,2 pour cent en un an un chiffre sans
précédent depuis
1985 tout cela évidemment tombe on ne
peut plus mal pour emmanuel macron et sa
majorité à nous jours maintenant du
premier tour des législatives
après un mois de silence le président se
serait résolu à revenir sur scène
d'après l'opinion ou dessins de cas
qu'on le voit montre elisabeth borde la
première mini exprimé ses doutes auprès
d'emmanuel macron tu étais censé
profiter de ton élan à la une également
ce matin la poursuite on en parlait dans
le journal de l'offensive nous dans le
donbass les troupes de moscou semble sur
le point de prendre le contrôle de la
ville clé de ces beraudo niet d
independence fait état de bombardements
russes incessants et d'un bain de sang
dans la région et le quotidien
britannique s'alarme de voir si véro
donetsk devenir une autre mario paul la
ville du sud de l'ukraine tombée aux
mains des russes il ya dix jours environ
presque cent jours après le début du
conflit la résistance ukrainienne
s'effrite face à l'intensification des
attaques de l'armée russe à lyon ce
matin le gratuit 20 minutes dans un long
texte publié par de new york times joe
biden promet que washington va renforcer
son soutien à l'ukraine notamment vous
l'avez dit via la livraison de systèmes
de missiles plus avancés dans le même
temps le président américain assure que
les états unis ne cherchent pas une
guerre entre le temps et la russie je le
cite bien que je ne sois pas d'accord
avec monsieur poutine et que je trouve
ces actions scandaleuses les états unis
ne cerne pas de provoquer son éviction à
moscou soutient joe biden quelques mois
de l'ouverture aujourd'hui en turquie de
la principale association féministe du
pays et l'ouverture du procès de l'ulg
nous stopperons les féminicides accusé
de mener des activités contraires au
droit et la morale totalement passée
sous silence par la presse turque est
présenté par le figaro comme une
nouvelle manifestation de l'accélération
de la répression en turquie aurait shape
ardoines prépare déjà les élections de
l'année prochaine le temps explique que
les féministes constitue aujourd'hui le
dernier rempart de la société civile
face au président turc d'après le
quotidien suisse ces femmes sont les
seuls ou presque désormais à l'avoir pas
déserté les rues sous l'effet de la
répression de la presse tentative de
putsch de juillet 2016 le temps hélène
qui consacre sa une à un événement
capital autrement je trouve a beaucoup
parlé à partir de demain les
célébrations du jubilé
d'elisabeth 96 ans d'existence 70 ans de
règne une longévité exceptionnelle qui
fait des envieux donnez moi le même
teckel bois demande une cliente dans un
salon de thé dans le dessein de
chappatte elizabeth ii paraît-il plutôt
adepte du martini selon la légende si
les alcools forts lui sont désormais
interdits la souveraine britannique paul
il reste une passionnée de corps guillot
point que ces adorables toutous court
sur pattes devra jouer un rôle de
premier plan lors des célébrations qui
débuteront demain le washington post
précise que des images de corps qui
orneront les objets décoratifs de ce
jubilé des oreillers des tasses mais
aussi des biscuits que des sculptures de
corps qui ont déjà été installés un peu
partout dans les rues de londres et que
lors de la procession finale de dimanche
est bien une marionnette géante de la
reine sera entouré d'une meute de corbie
marionnettes si les cauris et les
célébrations de ce jubilé vous hérisse
dégel poil sachez que the guardian a
concocté un petit guide de survie à
votre intention le seul quotidien
républicain britannique recommande
notamment à ses lecteurs insensible au
charme de la royauté de se réfugier
secret ces quatre prochains jours j'en
perds mon latin dans des zones
inaccessibles à la 3g la 4g et la saint
jean merci m